let's see what the problem is
so my phone has been on airplane mode
i'm going to unlock it
i'm going to take a picture of lex
ridden
now if i can i'm going to tweet that
picture out
great but here's the weird part about it
yeah um
that picture sitting
with lex today
this th this ladies and gentlemen is how
the sausage is made
okay in so doing yes
i have just sent um
a picture of you and a tiny piece of
text
all over the planet that has arrived
at if statistics tell the truth just
under half a million different accounts
and then more from sharing and so on and
we have well
been some of those accounts are dead we
don't really know how many places it
went
yeah but the key issue with that tweet
is that that is a non-local phenomenon
yes so i just
broadcasted to an entire planet somebody
in uganda
is reading that at the same time as
somebody in uruguay
there is no known solution
to have so many people with the ability
to communicate
non-locally because locality was part of
the implicit nature of speech inside of
the constitution
friction locality there were all sorts
of other aspects to speech
so if you think about speech as a bundle
i like this then it got unbundled
and some of those aspects that we were
naturally counting on to
the impact of speech aren't present
and we don't have the courage to say i
wonder if the first amendment really
applies
in the modern era in the same way or we
have to work through an abstraction
either we probably have to amend the
constitution or we have to abstract it
properly
and that issue is not something we're
facing up to i watch
us constantly look backwards
we don't seem to try to come up with new
ideas and new theories nobody really
imagines that we're going to be able to
wisely amend the constitution anymore in
the inside of the united states many
people
abroad will say why are these guys
talking about the u.s it's a u.s centric
program
well that's because nobody knows where
this program lives
the fact by the way that you and i
happen to be in a physical place
together
is also bizarre it could be anywhere it
doesn't really matter that it happens to
be here
so the difference between logical
between physical local non-local
frictional non-fictional
it's the same thing with firearms
nobody imagined that the gatling gun
was going to be present when you had to
reload a musket
and that's fascinating to think about
i mean you you're exactly right that the
nature of this particular freedom that
seems so foundational to the
to this nation to what made
this nation great and perhaps much of
the world that is great made it great
is changing completely can we try to
reason through how the ideal
freedom of speech is to be changed i
mean
i guess i'm struggling it feels really
wrong
perhaps because i wasn't paying
attention to it it feels really wrong to
ban donald trump
now from twitter to ban not just the
president that's really wrong
to me but this particular human for
being
uh divisive but then when there is an
incitement of violence
that is an overused claim but
perhaps there was uh actual
uh brewing of local violence happening
so one of the things i know was
happening on parlor
is people were
scheduling meetings together in physical
space so
you're now going going back from this
dynamic social large scale people from
uganda people from all over the world
being able to
communicate you're now mapping that into
now back meeting
in the physical space that is uh similar
to what the founding
but the violence were digital if
ransomware
suddenly was unleashed um
true the key issue is the abstractions
so what was freedom of speech as a
bundle
and now it's and then how do we abstract
the bundle
into the digital era do you think we
just need to raise the question and talk
about it do you have
do you have ideas because i'm sure i
have ideas but the key point is
that i'm not even welcome in mainstream
media
i've never seen you on mainstream media
do you do mainstream media so we
we exist in part of an alternate
universe because the mainstream media
is trying to have a coherent story which
i
have called the gated institutional
narrative and the institutions pretend
that
they plug their fingers uh in their ears
and pretend that nothing exists
outside of msnbc talking to cnn about
what was in the new york times
as covered by the washington post and so
that's effectively like a professional
wrestling promotion
where they you know the undertaker faces
off against hulk hogan and
rowdy roddy piper okay well
that's very different than mma
you